i mean it's just been 18 months of
difficulty but um you know i think that
we're really
ecstatic to be back on stage we're
really ecstatic that we can go out and
do stuff now and
i mean you know the 18 months was
difficult but we used the time well
because we we made a new album called
the journey so that you know every cloud
has a silver lining as they say so so we
did that but
to be playing rewind festival
and henley on sunday
it's it's amazing you know we it's not
our first gig we've we've done a few we
did rewind off we did let's rock
but um
you know this is a big one for us you
know really looking forward to this
sunday rewind is fantastic look tell me
graeme how are you getting on with the
new boy
not very well actually uh
no listen
kevin's command you know and if you
think about it i mean this is it's over
four years ago since you know things
changed for us in in that department so
yeah kevin's came in um he's done a
fantastic job and he's he's given a a
new lease of life to us we've written
some new songs which was
you know i felt that
after the
last thing i stepped out
it was time for us to do something
musical and you know that's what kevin
enabled us to do so he's been doing an
amazing job i just think kevin it must
you know it's a it's tough for you isn't
it in the sense that you know you get
sort of a couple of years under your
belt as it were and get try and get your
your feet under the table and then
you've got the time out where people
sort of
maybe forget i mean i've got to be
honest i've forgotten there's been all
the changes so so this is this but this
is your chance now to sort of really
establish yourself within the band in
the public eye isn't it
yeah i suppose i mean yeah it was
obviously really difficult because i
think we kind of got a little bit of
momentum going uh just before
the pandemic hit so
we were out sort of gigging a lot doing
festivals and in the uk and abroad
and doing our own tours and
and yeah i felt like we'd sort of
gathered you know gained a bit of
momentum and then obviously so
everything just stopped and it and it's
a little bit like that to be honest like
graham said we've done quite a few
festivals recently and i still get those
those pre-show nerves of like how many
people know
you know the different line up to the
band and you know it does it does sort
of i feel like i'm sort of having to
prove myself every time i go on stage
but um
but you know i'm enjoying the um
what would i say the challenge of it and
then
just playing with the guys you know i
mean
these gigs have been unbelievable so far
just to get back out on stage and and
it's it's just unbelievable how much you
realize how much you've you've missed it
over the last sort of year and a half so
i mean what import of
in terms of the new album kevin i mean
graham seems to be indicating that you
know you've been quite quite a spur for
for getting some new tracks down and
getting some new ideas tell us about the
album
yeah i mean obviously like graeme said
you know
i guess like the the bonus to come out
of the last sort of 18 months has been
that we've been able to to write but
it's not come without his challenges
obviously um
we've been sort of writing songs over
zoom and recording stuff remotely i mean
pretty much all the album is recorded in
our own home studios so
and
but at the same time it's been a real
sort of
there's a real sense of achievement to
get it done and
and i think it's great as well so um
yeah it's
i can't wait for people to hear the new
the new music and obviously it's it's my
first original stuff with the guys and
then
and i'm really proud of it and obviously
so
i suppose it sets me apart as well from
singing all the the old stuff as much as
i absolutely love but it gives me a you
know
i hate to say it guys we're out of time
uh but it's really good to talk to you
both look forward to hearing the new
music